quand pleure la petite fille mon sourire
s'arrête au grille la tout au bord de
ces ciles je cherche mon
chemin plus une étoile ne briille je
m'évapore dans le vide de la solitude de
blanche de sa
nuit le cafar ça vous prend par la main
n'importe
quand même quand les gens voudrai faire
tant et
temp même s'il vous faisait les pieds au
mur le cafard vous bouffe l'azure et les
larmes vous font au
visage comme des
rides quand pleure la petite fille mon
sourire s'arrête ou grille la tout au
bord de ses ciles je cherche mon
chemin plus une étoile ne brille je
m'évapore dans le vide de la solitude
blanche de sa
nuit un amour ça vous griffe le cœur
n'importe
quand même quand le soleil voudrait
briller tant et
temps même si le printemps raconte aux
fleurs que l'hiver mort avant l'heure tu
te moquequ bien de leur couleur quoi
qu'onend
dit
quand pleure la petite fille mon sourire
s'arrête grille la tout au bord de ces
ciles je cherche mon
chemin plus une étoile ne brille je
m'évapore dans le vide de la solitude
blanche de ce
nuit
[Musique]
pleure pas peti fille
ouvre-moi cette grille met tout au bord
de tes ciles montre-moi le
chemin dis-moi qu' esttoi le briille
emporte-moi dans le vide de la solitude
blanche de
ta
[Musique]
nuit